L'inquiétude se lit sur
les visages et l'anxiétéee
répand d'heure en heure.
Leur pays, la Russie, a franchi
un point de non ururur,
ils veulent partir avant
qu'il ne soit trop tard.
- Je suis déprimée. Je suis très
déçue et j'ai l'impression que
nous sommes comme des Allemands
... maintenant.
- Ceux qui en ont la possibilité
comme Pauline, prennent la route
pour la Finlande ou la Lettonie;
en autobus ou en train.
Nous sommes à St -Pétersbourg,
et la gare routière se remplit
à vue d'oeil.
Le prochain départ est pour
Riga, dans 5 minutes.
(cris de protestation)
- Les gens sortent manifester,mt
interdit. Les gens sont arrêtés
sous nos yeux, montés dans
des autobus. Ça fait partied'uni
est à son comble. Notre équipe a
même été chassée des lieux.
Impossible de filmer et ce,
y compris les médias qui
diffusent ce qui est jugée
de la désinformation par
le Kremlin, s'exposent désormais
à une peine qui peut aller
jusqu'à 15 ans de prison.
Une censure dite militaire, qui
vient d'emporter un des piliers.
La radio Echo Moscou a été
débranchée hier soir par
le Kremlin.
SERGEI BOUTMAN, vice directeur
Echo Moscou
- Et on s'y attendait parce que
le climat est très mauvai
très tendu, très tendu.
- Son crime, avoir utilisé
le mot "invasion" russe pour
décrire l'horreur qui s'abat
sur l'Ukraine au lieu ou lieu
d'intervention militaire.
- Cette guerre est abominable.
Il faut dire ce qu'on...
ce qu'on p p p p p parce que
c'est notre profession,
mais aussi notre attitude,
mon attitude... civique.
Et après, on verra.
- Il y a de moins en moins
d'antidote à la télévision
d'État qui la raconte
cette intervention au peuple,
telle qu'elle est dictée par
le Kremlin.
"Chers téléspectateurs, dit
l'animateur, voici maintenant
une vidéo qui vous montre
des soldats canadiens apprendre
aux fascistes comment attaquer
une école."
- Un message qu'
n'oserait jamais remettre en
question, jamais de la vie.
Le moment est venu pour
les Ukrainiens, dit-elle
d'ouvrir grand les oreilles,
lululululululus sympathiser
avec les nazis. Le gouvernement
a beau essayer de leur cacher
la réalité, les sanctions
commencent à peser lourd sur
le peuple.
Les multinationales plient
bagage : Boeing, Nike, Apple
et la liste s'allonge.
Le rouble est en chute libre,
encore aujourd'hui.
Son père l'a déposé à la gare,
il prend lui aussi l'autobus
pour la Finlande dans quelques
minutes. Il craint d'être
conscrit pour la guerre
en Ukraine. ♪
Si les ukrainiens fuient
les bombes,ces russes, eux,
fuient un pays qui est devenu
toxique.
Ici Tamara Alteresco
Radio Canada, St-Petersburg